three two one
never do that again
[Music]
will just three two one'd us in and it
was pretty uncomfortable
and he went like deeper than normal yeah
three two
the only time he's ever sounded
commanding yeesh is the word i believe
the kids call it
cringe
um tell me about your week that you can
remember of it
you know what's really funny is that i i
had it i was like yes
i know what i'm going to tell you i know
exactly and now you're choking i'm
bombing
um i
did i don't know why
i bombed i just blew and write it down
on it you should write it down
yeah you go okay
uh not a lot did a couple podcasts which
somehow
if i have anything to do it occupies so
much space in my head
what do you mean i mean like if i have
to do a taurus podcast at six
i'm like thinking about it every day you
can't relax like
i gotta when the podcast comes every
so i did two podcasts i did and then i
just had a bunch of uh
zooms uh about uh chase
bank heard of it um and uh
many zooms many many zombies and
many many exciting zooms and casting and
approving drugstore art
and uh cabins i'm approving cabins
is this is this car okay yeah
do you kevin hart uh
wardrobe yep
three choices okay the middle that's the
one of the things about commercials i
have no
i do not care there are commercial
directors who are like
super i call them um doorknob directors
because they're like that doorknob's
not right and i just they get because
it's the only thing they do
right so they make it like their
masterpiece
don't worry about the the next thought
like which commercial has been a
masterpiece
don't you're thinking too much so i just
i don't i just care about like what are
they saying right
what are they gonna say where are they
gonna do it all right i'm good but i
don't care about like buttons and i just
don't care
does it feel like at some point do you
just want to say
i i don't care whatever you want promise
i can't
really say that i'll talk about it
euphemistically like guys
this is not one of my areas of passion
so um
i whatever you guys want unless it's
egregious
i'm not against it right and also it's
kevin's gonna just wear what he wants to
wear
the protocols and the rules one in like
hollywood production
yeah seems so important
until someone doesn't care yeah and it's
like yeah
oh yeah i don't care i'm the director i
don't care
kevin doesn't know that anyone's having
this conversation
he's just gonna show up and go like what
am i wearing all right
i did a commercial once and they put my
hair
the wardrobe the hairstylist put my hair
in a bun
and then wardrobe wanted to put me in a
beanie and i was like
i look like i have cancer mm-hmm no
and no one no they're like wait
someone's got to wear the beanie
you know yeah like oh my god you know
why someone's got to wear the beanie
because they put it in a power point
yeah they put it in a deck
that's what happens oh so they're afraid
someone's gonna where's the beanie
exactly there's the being agreed to like
they don't remember it's
whatever i took it a funny thing i took
it off i was like you're not wearing
this yeah you crazy i'm on
tv and i no one cared no one thought
about it no one
that they either did or didn't buy the
product
based on that it was bing everyone
um brought not a sponsor
we have a we have a sponsorship
conversation i have off-camera when
we're done
oh we're done here uh so i did that i
did a little stand-up
on friday and saturday and
some new jokes that are good and uh
that's always you know
you know i love that you know i love a
new joke that works
so pretty amazing and then i went
and i was getting a burger
after one of my spots on saturday my
buddy dan levy wanted to meet up
not not the guy from the city not not
the si not the
famous guy yeah the not famous family
comedian writer
he was like oh we should have dinner and
i so i was like i'm getting a burger at
night if you want to meet me
so then he met me and then
uh my friend iko who works used to work
at the lab factory
and tiffany haddish came and met us
because he was so sweet she's the
sweetest yeah
amazing and but i think
tiffany and iko were like expecting more
because
me and dan were just eating a burger in
my car
and then they showed up and it's like
there's nowhere to go
so we're just standing on western eating
eating it was pretty sad but it was did
you guys have a good
conversation yeah and also there was a
crime
that was a guy some for some reason
climbed on a
started sprint very weird crime
we watched him up a building start spray
painting he climbed up a building
he cli yeah like he climbed it was weird
and then tiffany was like neil you
better move your car because
they're gonna have to get a fire engine
here to get him down like she knew how
it was gonna go down exactly
and sure enough though i didn't get
parked in i didn't get blocked
yeah uh but i still think they
are not satisfied with their
journey to um
to place the burger place i think they i
felt like you mean like the girls
tipping were not could not have been
pleased with what happened
but not that i was like we weren't
around we were eating a burger
anyhow did you warn them i didn't i
didn't think they were you know
like this isn't going to be yeah i don't
know
it seemed obvious it seemed obvious
so anyhow so
good g again not a good
good afternoon america and uh here's
another by the way right as we're
recording
there's been a school shooting where in
wichita i believe knoxville
it's like we're making up for the
last year of no shootings yeah um
one dead officer wounded um
yeah so so yeah it's just disgusting
it's disgusting and uh
to quote the onion uh only country where
this happens says there's nothing that
can be done
um it's they they you know they do it
funnier but
um so the kid yesterday dante wright uh
got shot in minnesota the officer
yelled taser thought she was gonna tase
him and then
hit the wrong button and shot him and
now he's dead and
um i don't know i don't know what to i
don't
i don't know it seems like it's a gun
issue
seems like it's a gun issue but and i
don't even think this is one of these
things that that never happens to white
people
or i think that's one of those things
maybe it it she choked because he was
black and you know how
cops have a preternatural exaggerated
fair black people
so then she went for the wrong but like
who knows but now you're into motives
it's it's when she didn't want to shoot
him
seemingly she wanted to tase him i
i i do question yelling taser taser
taser
i mean do you yell gun gun gun no taser
they yell
they do yell taser they yell when
they're gonna shoot with a taser they
yell taser
they say like yeah they go taser not
like i'm going to tase you
it's like the sparks or the other cops
have to be like
cleared like corner it's like yeah it's
like when they defibrillate
the corner in service industry
corner at the restaurant and taser okay
tasering is the cornering of
police work got there yes um
okay because that i that for me looked i
was like this seems
no they yeah okay well i mean not like
it makes a difference but why
even if they didn't why would you think
she was covering up the fact that she
was shooting him
no but i do know that some cops will say
like let off a few warning shots after
the fact to look like to just cover
your bases for things i mean i think
cops assume they're filmed all the time
now because uh
well they are yeah well it's that
sometimes there are some but the body
cams
well she knew she had a body camera yeah
so i'm just
i feel like and then she said like holy
[ __ ] i shot him or something
i couldn't watch i was like i didn't
watch it i didn't watch it but she
shot him and then uh
said oh my god i shot him or something
uh
holy [ __ ] i just shot him so
the easy categorization
is a police officer killing on our black
men
the the the less
satisfying one is uh cop
means to tase somebody shoots them uh
uh who knows how long she's been a cop
who it
i there's just a bunch of different
there's ways to categorize it
that are not very senior officer okay
maybe like in her 80s
um um
yeah i don't know we can go into every
little example
right and see where was an
accident or some negligence or racism
or um an unchecked ego you know what i
mean
you can find examples of every kind of
like a small sub problem of a bigger
problem but i think the big problem is
obviously the relationship we have with
police and how we
lift them like just who the police think
they are you know what i mean
like that's kind of an overarching thing
and there's obviously so many reasons
why they think they are who they are but
i mean i've lived in different countries
police don't act like this everywhere by
the way they got rid of qualified
immunity
in a state maybe new mexico
did they do it in minneapolis i mean in
uh
new
yeah they got rid of they got rid of
qualified immunity
[Music]
uh yeah they got rid of qualified
immunity so um
uh that's a good start great start
that's like the
first state that legalized weed like
okay great let's get rid of qualified
immunity
there was another stat that's one of
those like i
um what that
places where there were blm protests
the murder rate went up
basically everywhere the main
the biggest 10 whatever the murder rate
went up
and it's so it's like
it's just one of these things like
either cop sulking statistical anomaly
right uh yeah they lead to more crime
uh in this whatever but the funny thing
is
uh when we talked about police budgets
and everyone's like that
look at the crime going up the budgets
were for the
following year the police had all their
money in 2020. no one was getting their
budget cuts for 2021 but somehow the
i don't know it was just this gray area
of people saying like oh look
more crazy it's like
10 increase in murders in the areas it's
a blm protest
but 2014 to 2019 they were somewhere
between a thousand six thousand more
homicides than would have been expected
uh if places would protest were on the
same trend as places that did not have
protests
that's one of those things like yeah
it's atlanta chicago
it's already high murder rate things
right um
this shits get soupy immediately
immediately because also
okay well at this point you have all
your benefits and amenities
in 2020. mm-hmm and if the murder rate's
going up
what explain is yeah if crime's going
into
the uh it's the they call you know
protester snowflakes and then
it's that thing of like well i guess i
can't be a coptic
what's your joke i guess we can't hit on
women anymore yeah it's that thing like
well i guess they can't hit on
can't even say hello to a woman it's
that it's the it's the
self-pity when they were outlawing
smoking
in in bars and they'd cut to a bartender
i'm not gonna be able to make a living
this couldn't be because you're a smoker
could it i don't i think they might
as well close down bars completely and
they're going to come and take our guns
and they give these [ __ ] morons
time so the if if it's cop sulking
yeah i i it's an
incredibly complicated issue um
and and what does what qualifies the blm
protest
you know what i mean we start getting
into it's like how many people were
there was it actually bill um
what what are we talking about um but
i will say that the dante right thing is
[ __ ] a tragedy and then you read
about him and he's like
he's it's worked in retail and
fast food restaurants he's got a kid he
had a learning disability dropped out of
high school
like a nice ostensibly a nice kid
i read that he was originally pulled
over
for his um air freshener air freshener
blocking his rear viewer yeah which
causes
which is the hundreds of thousands of
accidents every year are caused by air
fresheners apparently
literally i'm like it's that's such a
bad reason like even
argus has a joke on like i turned left
at the
at the tree it was just my airplane like
and nobody yeah air fresheners are not a
thing
to pull someone over because how big of
an air freshener was it also
how does that differ from a phone thing
on a
on a the phone right the phone charger
station
yeah that's legal but it better not make
the car smell better
um but also that it's hard for me to say
an
innocent mistake when the reason why
they pulled him over was for an air
freshener you know
like it's not feeling i don't really
innocent would they
have would they have pulled him over if
he was white you'd have to show me some
stats
about a number of people they that's one
who's been pulled over forever
in minnesota i have no [ __ ] idea but
what i'm saying is again
if white people get pulled over for that
fine if it's
if it's proportion if it's proportional
to
um population fine
i got no problem pulling people over for
air force yeah it's fair
but as we all know it's almost never
evenly distributed
so let's keep
advocating for better police work
and getting rid of qualified immunity
like that's kind of all
any of us can do at this point and it's
a [ __ ] tragedy
um like he it's a new car he's going to
get it washed
it's just we have such a weird relation
to police or maybe he got it
maybe he got the air freshener at the
car wash
you know not not important but i the the
relationship we have with police here is
on the you know in children's books like
you're friendly police officer
but they're very it's it's so
so weird where you go to different
countries police are not in your
business
you don't have like when i lived in
europe and i would tell them hey
you know and it's very easy to encounter
the police and
just living a non-like
non-criminal non-illegal non-rule
law-breaking life
yeah it's very easy to intercept the
place and have them be a part of your
life's amount
in america in america yeah you could
just be walking
yeah they will hurt i mean yeah they'll
whereas in other places
no one uplifts police like we do no one
makes them these pillars of the
community and
so important did you watch any of
exterminate all the birds
did i so why are cops
why are cops revered in america
relative to other countries
and if you look at exterminate all
brutes
the it's all mythology it's all
mythology of
taming the natives taming the
the there were a couple points in the
documentary where it's a little bit like
ah
not even an overreach but it's like
there's one
where he's doing all the lists of
helicopters
all military helicopters are named after
native american tribes
but then there was one like in country
is short for indian country which i was
like i don't think it's short for indian
country
right but it was just one of those like
um
but it's about taming
the natives it's just about so it's our
heroes who tame the natives
and if they are uh
if they're brown no nothing is too harsh
right of course because it's their their
savages
yes like what do you expect dealing with
savages
and they all believe it inherently
uh i think just by merit of like oh look
at the
you just hear but i can't
i've never done a ride-along but people
i have it's like the way they talk about
certain groups is
very the white people in the bible are
very different
yeah of course the white suspects the
black suspects there's a book
i read um [ __ ] i think it's called it's
called something like
very straight police or something and
it's a guy that
rode around with police for years and
he it's just quotes it's literally just
oh that's right it's not
uh yeah it's not a story it's just kind
of quotes of different police
the amount of you know
they don't they don't say the n word
well not in the book
right but i think he probably left it
out
my guess is they know better then it's
like you're just asking to get written
up
sure because you have to be like law
abiding something yeah when you're but
they'll say like scales
just some [ __ ] that's like what the [ __ ]
does that mean i'm surprised how many
because it was all anonymous yeah so
it's the only way they like let them
in but um the amount of
infidelities uh the amount of
uh cops like taking like breaks
to like cheat like something like
training day [ __ ] oh
absolutely it's like we are in
they even say that like women throw
themselves at us
yeah so there is this
relationship we have with cops and i
know and unfortunately
uh the positive is only for
also just let's take grace out of it
cops are not popular
they i can't get a read on it i can't i
literally i have jokes about them
one week it'll work next week it won't
and i don't even know why
crap it's in the news this week it'll do
well
right of course because it's anti-cop
right but
you know what it is it's uh everyone but
after january 6 it was like
oh these guys are really front line
right especially them capitol cats yeah
which yeah
yeah um if you're so for white people
generally cops are fake
are i think they're looked at favorably
yeah from far away
yeah the moment the cop comes close near
you
suspect trying to in trying to do their
job it's like
i pay your [ __ ] well then it becomes
a servant
they're the savages yeah then it's like
oh
what do you make before overtime oh 65
dollars
um and then over time he makes a million
um
but excellent uh but that's the yeah
like that's the
it's a mythology that we and they
do a they do provide a service
i don't wanna call i'm not i don't wanna
it's the thing i'm saying a couple weeks
ago call the cops i pay for them
to come and collect human trash
as i call it which is which is a horror
way to put it but
tell me i'm wrong they paid to i'm
paying them to
solve problems for me solve problems
that i can't solve
and don't want to solve it don't want to
solve don't get up
don't want to go outside don't want to
the amount of domestic [ __ ] they have to
deal with yeah the amount of just like
my sister-in-law and just like
[ __ ] man you your family couldn't handle
it right so you have to call the cops
um because the stats are
blind people don't want to see
statistically they don't want to see
cop uh cuts and police what do you mean
budget cuts they don't want to see like
black people like no we don't want
to defund the police like we need them
yeah most people don't want to defund
the police but it's like what is there
what can we do that's that's just
overall 82 percent don't support you
from the police
uh african-american yeah police viewed
less favorably but few want to
uh defund the police that was the
headline
um yeah so which so everyone
is conflicted the problem is there's no
word
what when there's a big problem
there's a big ass problem and no one
really knows what to do with it like no
one really knows what to do
i want perfect cops and i'm getting
guys who may or may not have gone to
college may have not have been good
students
may not be they're not extraordinary in
any way right
but i need them to be perfect
robocop it is perfect or not
super racist well the var is so low like
perfect is such a big jump yeah
but even like the
i think the
you listen to that podcast or something
about how they're trained
where it's like you just gotta go home
at night whatever it takes to go home at
night
and they get and they show video they
show dash cams of cops getting shot by
people they pulled over
so that's the thing that they don't show
them here's a million
uneventful pullovers and most people
haven't don't use their gun like that
yeah like a lot of cups some stat where
they like most haven't even used a gun
in the last year or last five years but
that's the thing all these
services like firefighters don't really
fight fires
no offense uh in california they do
because we have fire season
well thankfully we take we look after
him and have set the
we set the forest on fire to give him
something to do right
but you know a lot of firefighters like
my father
was a firefighter it's mo
that's why most of them are emts and
they go out on the same calls so
we see the fire trucks no one would dare
cut funding to the fire
fireman yeah because we see them yeah
like they're doing [ __ ] i don't know
what they're doing
but in the end they're actually fighting
ambulances for the same
thing so it's like it's a lot less
it's a lot less glamorous than
we always it's the least glamorous [ __ ]
in the world right
in the world other than you're cheating
on your wife every every day
uh for 45 minutes every day and you
gotta go honey i gotta do it you need to
tell your mistress you gotta go
um yeah so
it's like 50 of black respondents still
said we need more cops on the street
that was so but even that's like
um like that's just it yeah no one knows
what to think that's after george floyd
it's like
there's no clear like i will do this and
we'll do this and we'll do this because
even the defund the police people or the
refund the police people or whatever you
want to call them don't
really know we need police what the hell
no no of course but yeah they're so
utopian that they think that we don't
need police we need social workers
with vests um all it takes is one
person at a vest to get shot and then
it's over
yeah it's pretty much over that's the
problem uh
even i have the thought with the with
the dante wright thing
maybe a bunch of cops should have guns
and the other cop should have take
like but all it takes is one fight
or just retraining like train these
people i don't actually mind the money
cops make
200 000 over time fine whatever train
them
like make them worth two hundred
thousand dollars
they don't go to that much training for
how much money they make and too much
power they have but it's also
it's it's a thing you can never track
but it's like how many of them
are just harbor racist views for sure
but
if you really it's also there's not a
huge barrier to entry
so it's a lot easier for i don't know
the dude that just
was like maybe i'll just be a cop to
just go do that he's not becoming a
lawyer or even with something that has a
lot of training behind it because it's a
lot of investment
and i just think more it's a they don't
no one wants to go to school
yeah people don't want to go to study
they don't want to study [ __ ] i just
want to get out there
right [ __ ] bus scales throw scales
against fences
that's why there's technical colleges
like can be done in 18 months
but that's but these guys are like
jocks to begin with it's just a hard
thing
that you're getting jocks what are jocks
like they
love they see violence as like the first
second and third option
that's just what they're like they
that's like it's their love language
it's just [ __ ] violence so they it's
it's a job that requires
more
i think you can get all the training you
want if you then go to a bar and it's
like that can did that
or in your car in your squatty i don't
know what they call it
i was in marsquadi and uh uh
and they and then or your wife or your
brother
or your dad or your it's like they're
not
liberals right none of them are liberal
so they don't even
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
yeah you're right i don't know how to
come back anyone who wants to wear a gun
at work is not liberal right no
of course i just mean i'm not sure
because even a
doctor in the most potent town kind of
knows what he's doing
you know what i mean yeah so i'm just
wondering is there a way is there a
standard
to have everyone just at least on kind
of the same
like it's like you're so without
insulting them
let me say this it's not
a job that a evolved
intelligent person would want to do how
about that
but somebody needs to do it
somebody's got to do it how about if you
if you want if you want to be a gun
holding cop
you have you have liabilities like you
can't just
yeah i don't i i don't i i i'm i look
forward
i welcome the stats from new mexico come
on new mexico
to see if it's a different type of law
enforcement do you know the stats from
what's the town that did it without that
defunded their police
um in newark new york camden right
yeah i mean camden had nothing to lose i
think it was down actually like
26 or something um
crime plummeted after police were
disbanded
what's the catch i remember reading this
but i don't remember what the catch was
yeah well that's what i'm saying do we
just walk away from that headline or
are we monitoring if in 2012 we had 67
murders
crime was at record highs uh
every officer got fired in 2013 and they
had to reapply
only about 100 were offered the
opportunity to apply
and then 70 drop in homicides 40s
yeah i don't know why this isn't why are
we talking about this more
yeah camden also wasn't great you know
it's a good one
it was worse than not great it was awful
okay
i don't understand it i don't understand
how they did it
and why is that not why is this not a
a teachable moment
for everyone or just the like a template
yeah cause to camden it's not like it
was a nice little tiny village where
crime dropped canada wasn't good like
you're saying so
why can't this be why can't this be like
a pilot program for
oakland chicago uh i bet unions have
something to do with it
i bet i can't turn my back son that it's
guys talking like this i gotta reapply
i put my ass on the line every day for
11
[ __ ] years this movie here that's
throughout the whole podcast i love it
uh so i just thought of it and george
floyd
i haven't watched any more of the trial
but it seems
again moving on wide shot
seems like it's trending toward a
conviction
when everyone's like he should have done
it he shouldn't have done it he's a
supervisor
no he shouldn't have done it every
single
um and then they
there was like the george was no angel
thing that's
and it's like you know it's still
illegal to shoot non-angels or
you can't choke people the cops don't
say are you an angel before we start
are you an angel you're still not
allowed to like you can do drugs
one day and the next day the cops are
not allowed to sit on your
throat for eight hours eight minutes 46
seconds
well yeah it's also the law isn't here
to protect
nice people we like and by the way from
what i remember
the amount of fentanyl and meth in a
system was from like three or four days
earlier
it was a very small amount i could be
wrong but that was my recollection from
carl hart it's just funny so now we have
um
you know didn't they say it's a state of
emerging like the
the pill industry
the drug problem in america dealing with
like pills and mostly it's affecting
like mostly white people
they've declared that like a state of
emergency so the opioid addiction and
all that stuff so you can be
you know just stay a cat if a white
person died it would've just been like
it doesn't make a difference yeah
casualty
yeah a drug epidemic right
one day and then uh no angel
savage he's no angel if a white guy's on
fentanyl
you know with absolute certainty that
it's a
workplace injury that he's dealing with
and he is in no way an addict and he
through his [ __ ] risks a repetitive
stress
injury um you know don't you
dare imply that i like drugs because
they make me feel good
don't you [ __ ] dare now
yeah that i do these people do get
hooked and then they end up getting to
him they can't get fentanyl and then
they end up getting heroin and
fentanyl killed prince and killed but
it's
killed a lot of people it goes a long
way but it's like
i don't know i do think the argument is
going to
it's just gonna it's just what else can
okay the problem is that he has a right
to an attorney and they have to make
a defense yeah i mean yeah i mean yeah
they got to say something
that's how he's gonna his closing
statement's gonna get look i gotta say
something
okay uh
george floyd they found some fennel so
uh case dismissed um
now this i love come on iran
now this is near and dear to your heart
i know i'm sure your cousins work at the
nuclear facility
how rude that
this is the so iran
has nuclear facilities and but
israel and america can sabotage them
remotely and i gotta say just as a
cinematic device
it's [ __ ] excellent it's wrong it's
yeah it's like it's not even he no i
know literally
the last one was called stuxnet great
name um
and then this one they just go like they
can just make the centrifuge just spin
too fast remotely and then they just
explode the machine
and there's no spillage i actually
didn't get to
uh what
what was the there was an explosion
it's it damaged the centrifuges used in
rich uranium
um how can they hack that
let me tell you israel is the they are
the
they're they're the olympic gold they're
the
uh-huh they're the israel being israel
no they're
so good at hacking yeah what's going on
with them uh they have a
they have a big industry there like
that's other than silicon valley i think
that's like number two
yeah and uh and i gotta say
it's hypocritical because i don't like
when they hack us
when we get hacked like we got hacked
the
the whatever the wins solar winds or
whatever the [ __ ] it was called
the all of america got hacked it's
really bad we talked about it and it's
like but we do it too
i love this is like a i like this
because it's like a cut too
the funny thing is sir there's a problem
on generator five
z-z-z nothing wrong with the accent
um i did it with a dialect coach i
worked with a dialect coach
on sundays before the podcast that's
really fun
uh no it's iran you know
in a bad iran defense
a bad defense of iran i don't know about
the
iran vows to get revenge every time like
they never stop it's starting to be like
that's their care like
um i don't know speed racer just these
like
yeah well what are the parts this is the
format
of this thing everyone in the middle
east is [ __ ] psycho
right we can all agree revenge is fine
but do they
get it ever uh
it's a little pinky well again they'll
play the old americans have the
watches we have the time like we haven't
gotten it
in this era but like they're playing the
long game oh they're like
your day will come yes oh trust me
because they know
that and then it's like america and
israel are [ __ ] psychos
so they'll just be psycho it's just and
kill your guy at the airport
for nothing yeah now having said i
i love making the point that everyone
every american that is against
israel having nuclear weapons also
believes in the right to bear arms
so whoops one of them one of them iran
sorry what did i call it
israel oh yeah but is israel doesn't
have nuclear weapons
wink uh uh yeah they don't they want
iran to not have nuclear weapons but
everyone should be able to have a gun
and if you look at a map of iran look at
how many american bases
surround iran uh-huh and somehow it's
like
you better no oh no i don't know yes
don't worry about it
yeah don't worry about it don't worry
about it okay there we go
so you surround me you surround my house
and are like
you better not have any guns in there
but you're surrounding me with guns
yeah america would never put up with
that [ __ ]
no i mean we're still mad at cuba for
like having a missile
70 years ago we're like you [ __ ]
enjoy this [ __ ]
enjoy i hope you like rice because
that's what you're gonna be eating
because you had one missile
in 1961. [ __ ] you forever
um anyhow uh because we're psychos
i i want to see you just recap history
i you'd be you know how like uh
was it colin quinn yeah you know he did
history one that was pretty good
my worry with those shows is always i
don't know when
i over simplify it to the point where
i'm like self open but that's
kind of right no like we had they had a
six missile and
and and then castro was just
wasn't wouldn't is like an immovable
object irresistible force
no it's hilarious no i'm not i'm i'm not
we got a cigar for you
explodes you can't you miss me [ __ ]
it's it's eddie's joke
with
[Music]
now i didn't know what this was the blm
houses
i know go to new york post look at me
porsche
uh one of the founders of blm
uh-oh binge bought a
uh home
in um
like basically malibu and it's
caused one point it's it's one of these
things where
it's just not a good look should black
activists have have to live in squalor
of course not
but it's very easy to paint you
into yeah to paint you into a
i don't think i'm i'm rich technically
and i
[ __ ] donate to
causes and go to marches and stuff it
doesn't it's just that
i think if you sell yourself as
well they have they a couple of them
went to like marxist training camps
not even kid training camps like they
took a marxism class or some [ __ ]
so they go like these marxists and no
one knows what that means
do we know where she got her money
uh it
we don't know but the i think what
people on the right are saying and i
think some black people are saying it's
like
it looks like you took the money from
blm and bought a house
that's probably not what happened yeah
it's probably not what happened but
it's but it's too
cartoony that's a cartoony world i
didn't
ever follow up with what did blm as a
whole do with all the donations they got
last year do we
what i've gotten information wise on
that is there is a trust
that holds the money so the people her
she's not in charge of the money
right there's like a trust there's like
a separate thing
and they kind of have to apply for to
get some of the money
um but yeah it's just not like somebody
pointed out
farrakhan lives in the hood yeah
like does he have to probably not
but to not live in the hood is
too big uh it's
too it's too easy uh it makes you too
easy to target right
and it's like you can't it's like can
you be
uh well the funny thing is they all
signed development deals which is
the funniest [ __ ] in the world they've
all signed television and film
production deals which is like
well if anyone knows it it's a bunch of
protesters
if anyone knows narrative and
entertainment protesters
um so that's a whole other like
corporation's trying to buy silence
trying to like just
yeah hey clean me up stand with me
would you and then they go we gave we
did
we we re we have uh members of blm as
part we have deals with many of them and
we have on go
watch what happens if they don't buy the
pitches
which one which of course they're not
going to do yeah it's like
no one gets what i'm what we're saying
is these people have deals
at uh warner brothers and a bunch of
production companies
all that means is warner brothers gives
you an office and gives you a
small butt they give you a salary and
they give you a budget
to buy projects with but you have to go
and pitch to them
what the project is and and then once
you buy the product then you have to get
the script
they they're my my bet
is none of these things are going to get
very far because what they want is
the photo up right so
because none of these people have any
experience in entertainment or
like i said stories like what makes it
yeah so
anyhow uh it's a lot more complicated
it's pretty complicated um so
the house is lovely and she probably she
bought it lovely house and again
why is this news i get why it's news but
if there is no smoking gun
or there's no there there it feels
what do you need from she can't just get
a nice house what do you need
where does malcolm x need to live where
does martin luther king need to live
where does
jesse jackson need to live i mean jesse
jackson kind of had less credibility
because it might
i don't know where he lived but if you
told me he lived in a white neighborhood
it wouldn't shock me
um do they need to live in a black
neighborhood
that's one of those things of like i
don't know i don't know what
the what the
what the rules are but it's a very
easy thing to target somebody and say
like if you love
black lives so much why aren't any near
you
right well that's because that's
basically the argument it's like
i don't get when people move to mountain
tapanga i don't get when people
well it's the ultimate cry for help um
moving to malibu it's the last refuge of
a scoundrel okay
i just no it's i mean that's a whole
other issue
that's just why would you why would you
you might as well not live in l.a
i don't mean i don't mean distance wise
i mean
it's the most white
it's such a specific kind of community
malibu is the best of them yeah
it's hippie it's fake hippie it's fake
hippie new age a new age open-minded but
very close-minded
you know so i i don't know it's weird i
mean my friend
one of my friends is married into a very
like
at the wedding someone yelled third
generation melbourne
oh um so this is like a lot of
bring the car pull the car around and
okay what's going on here white malibu
eighty-four percent
eighty-four percent white uh eight not
white non-hispanic
that's fine i it's it's better than
huntington
whatever
newport beach it's better than the
orange county beaches right like that's
it's in terms of a beach most beach
enclaves are
white anyway right for a variety of
reasons right of course the inkwell
the hit movie from 1994 um
about the black part of martha's
vineyard you didn't know
it's very good is it good yeah i like
the script actually
you that's how old i am wow neil
neil's old uh read the script
i was like really i saw that on like
syndication
on like a movie that read the script i
believe uh dave was up for it maybe
who was in it it was the guy that lorenz
tate there who's great who's going and
still looks 20.
uh anyhow um
i it's it's an unfair thing
i a friend of a friend is friends with
another
activist and his response was like yeah
that's why i live in a one bedroom in
harlem
like because i can't it's not like i i
can afford
to live in a in a white neighborhood but
you kind of can't
if you want to walk the walk or it's
just
better it doesn't mean that she's a
better or worse activist
it leaves you over it just you know this
is the thing that i don't think people
expect
is the blowback is like
you know what they're gonna do it's like
carl hart with the drug stuff right
he didn't fit i don't think he knew
how weird and harsh the blowback was
gonna be because they went at him like
three weeks ago the new york post
yeah of course but it's weird that he
didn't you
think you can imagine it i haven't
spoken to him so i don't know but like
no you're not he got a new york he got a
new york times article
this week that was good and he was on
the daily show which is good
um yeah uh but
like you kind of have to if you're gonna
say i do heroin
no one's on your side like no one in the
media is on your side
like uh so but i don't think
like he on the breakfast club i think he
was kind of like wait what the [ __ ] like
he got kind of
like wait you guys aren't he got kind of
like [ __ ] sandmanned off the
breakfast club
hey hey hey um and uh
and he i think he assumed that they'd be
on his side and they
weren't crazy yeah they're not on
anybody's i mean well they're not
anybody's but he he's taking the hardest
side to be
yeah behind he's taking the action
the challenging side the motion and he
didn't bring up
all he had to do was just bring up
incarceration yeah
it's like and you neutralize it it's
he's not
used to hand-to-hand arguments he's used
to activate
like you should i really should i mean i
wish i could have
done like a training with him like
here's what no [ __ ]
hammer time hammer time every time
college
um anyhow uh
so blm yeah it's that's what's gonna
happen
it's what's gonna happen you have to
throw a perfect game
for these people and people white
white people the crown
um what is it uh now dmx
i don't your tone is too happy neil what
the hell
i know dmx dmx uh uh
[ __ ] died which we talked last week
we didn't like where it was headed
and it went where we were afraid it
would go
and it's just like
why it's just [ __ ]
bummer bummer bummer cause he's
he was he just had an incredibly rough
upbringing
it's just he got the system like
like sort of he's gone through every
system
yes you know the in his childhood his
husbandhood yeah everything and then
the fame system yeah starting all that
[ __ ]
yes it's he's been through everything
there's a really good thing i don't know
if they put it in the movie
uh in the motley crew book uh
called the dirt uh they did a netflix
movie that
pete davidson i didn't watch but um but
they talk about the
ferris wheel of fame and like the
there's just like a
buzz saw at the end just like shoots you
into [ __ ] chips
um and yeah you got eaten up by that got
eaten up i mean
dr like every he had no
it's not like he never got a break but
he just had i here's
here's a story that i that i kind of
forgot about okay
so when he did chappelle show
he got there and there was like a skate
park nearby
and he might have had his like one of
those remote-controlled cars but i was
like
i feel like he'd want to see the skate
park so i like walked him over to the
skate park
and uh dave afterward
was like how was he max and i was like
he struck me as like a hurt little kid
like that was the energy and dave goes
yep he goes he goes
we are two men like don't he was kind of
like
don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] we're in the
same boat as him
and it like he was a
he was like incredibly
soft in the middle like all like like um
swiss beats made a video of saying like
he was just he was
all empathy and all heart and that's the
kind of guy that
some of the lyrics you look at it are
just like wow
but still because he's so warm
and because he's so human and because
he's so
hard he's not gonna get canceled
no and also he really
i feel like his expression of his trauma
was so
like raw and real that yeah it all
everyone really took it as expression
like just kind of
the hurt getting the hurt out yeah
that's what it felt like in the most
like not a bitch-ass way like just it
was like
every day you can do it it was like yes
yes yes yes it's the bing reigns
the ving rhames pulp fiction scene as
hip-hop
yeah it was it just every guy could
bleed a little bit through those lyrics
blows my blood
uh
yeah so yeah but the thing is that i
think
i i kind of thought he like the with
wasn't he on i only fix my life yeah
i just felt like cat leave
and then he was on dr phil or something
he needed
help he needed help he needed to be in a
12-step program yeah of course
like he needed a minder he needed
he was an addict and
and like was either
binging or like down yeah you know
and um and
yeah it's just like in very sad
um so this lady got a lot of blue black
blue blue black blue black
uh for writing
so for writing an article blush blush
blush
uh for writing an article that
like let's remember dmx and support him
while this is before he died
by going through all the houses he lost
oh yeah i saw that
yeah and everyone was i'm like ladies
yeah it was two weeks ago it was new
york pubs that's just what they do
i know it's what they do but i don't
think it's right i'm just saying it's
like
why are we no he was in the hospital
like yeah do we need to
i just i mean of course social media
off deleted all of her you know
all of her contacts i feel bad canceling
this lady but she changed her name and
got plastic surgery
i feel bad canceling this lady but it
was so insensitive
yeah black white white lighting
um uh yeah that's funny that thing about
purchasing they said dmx and they always
come with like
beyonce and dmx have no jenna i'm sorry
beyonce and jay-z have bought
dmx's wait they did not no of course
they didn't
also you know what i knew it was fake
when it said they bought his masters for
10 million dollars
just so low what what i it's
i don't know how i don't know if it is
low it's a matter of hits and
uh radio play and streams and
uh projections yeah you don't think
that's still low for dmx
i don't know i have no idea i don't know
if they're
i mean i don't know i have no idea i
genuinely have
i know so little that i repeated the
exact same phrase twice in a row yeah
um yeah but i love that there's always
these stories of
beyonce doing something amazing it's
like no and they're not even like what
happened
yeah no they just come in like angels
and like yeah i
would yeah um so
but swiss beats made a really nice video
about them and
um and it's just
sad yeah and it's also sad for me
because like people my age are dying and
it's not
crazy also it's sad for neil you guys
okay
i wouldn't say it's sad for me it's more
like hey
yeah your time's coming up neil oh boy
naruto to the front oh my peer
um yeah
is there one that it was a little too
close
or do they just keep getting no because
it's
it's when when you get into natural
causes is when
that's what i'll worry these all have
mitigating circumstances
a lot of it's like harris whittles like
druggies like there's
there's overdoses that's not an overdose
but that's like a
slow motion overdose right um
[Music]
and like wear and tear overdose because
he was old when he was 20.
like he like i'm sure if they did like a
scan of his heart was funny like what
yeah like you've been through a lot so
anyhow that's a tragedy and i posted the
spell show performance and i posted
he was in top five yeah and chris's
movie
and uh i forgot i forgot
it's a true rust and power king it is a
true wrestlemania and it's uh
and i may i won't get into it but
uh i don't want to make it i kind of
want to get into it you guys don't know
you guys don't like it when i make
things about it
oh he's mad so i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna say that i pitched a
joke to dmx that he did in chris's movie
well i would never say that wow i forgot
about it bianca in the scene that you
posted i
well wow you hate to you hate it
i'm not gonna make this about me i'm not
i never met the guy
i just heard his music like everybody
else someone was like [ __ ] you for
making this about you i'm like i just
posted a thing on a show i did
that he was on i liked that glitch yeah
[ __ ] funny
um him yelling at the dj
and swiss beats laughing in the
background makes me laugh so hard cause
it's like when your friend at work gets
in trouble and you're like
oh [ __ ] um anyhow prince philip
the dmx of england um as he's known
uh uh he died also
and you know where he's going first
thing
that mummy parade no makeup
nothing he's going as is he's good walk
into the mummy parade
get him in car number 23 ready
he is set ready for the mummy parade
um yeah mommy ready yeah we go to the
daddy can we go to the mummy parade ah
that's what his picture looks like to me
ah
i'm scared to make fun of dead people
no it's not it's not scary it's like
yeah it's like
it's like it's like he's frankenstein
yeah like he couldn't even speak english
after all i did
oh my god neil's face right now i can do
i do good old man i worked my time
style coach tyler coach thank you again
dialect coach
um i have nothing to say about him i
don't
care about the [ __ ] crowd you know i
don't like those people
we don't know what they are but i don't
know if you're worth your [ __ ] tell me
what you are i can tell you who i am he
really can't
i can tell you what i've done i can make
specific jokes pitch to specific rappers
in specific instances
but this prince philip i need the
receipts
prince i would call you queen but you're
a prince
um anyhow do you have anything to add on
prince philip
i'm just enjoying this yeah i like the
show
uh yeah just not even [ __ ] just like
okay um 99 like
yeah what do you want how much more do
you want you were prince
and you lived 99 years they were cousins
they were right they were cut prince
i wonder if she's saying that like my
cousin died um
queen wise that uh my one of my cousins
my husband died
that's fine
all right now this is one of these
things where i tried not to stop the car
to look and it still kind of got in my
car
it got in my car so that
got out and she
kim kardashian started dming every sight
being like can you please take this down
my grandmother yeah uh posted it
and it's coffee written i don't like
women who don't do their own taxes this
is what kim said
she said it was there was a copyright
but she
miswrote copyright it just was all weird
anyways
then um people were saying are you
serious
like first of all whatever not even the
funny thing that women
think when it comes to like pictures or
how they look or
whatever i always want to say like you
know i have girlfriends right
you know i see women first thing in the
morning you know i know what women
actually look like and not in perfect
lighting
it's like i know what women actually
look like without hair and makeup
and you know what that is they look like
their
trailer trash cousin from out of town
most women without hair and makeup just
look like uh
i don't know your cousin was in town is
your is my girlfriend
have you seen my girlfriend yeah and
it's so rude um
but it's fine it's fine it's not like
it's just
funny sometimes we're like wow that's a
that's an after photo
wow
sometimes it's wow how big the
difference is but
you're still good looking it's just like
wow
so that's going to be a while for me
it's so well for me
so basically this photo came out they
tried to scrub the internet of it
but the backlash was really that she
wrote a thing
responding to all of this saying you
know i'm always the ugly sister i'm
always a fat sister i'm never
like i'm sorry if i just don't want
this ugly ass photo of me out yeah which
it's fine it's just
it's did she ask for any of the old
kylie photos back
because there's some wild ones out there
from when she was 15. so and it's like
the who that's a who that's a that's
nice
is that a that's a wow for you dog um
so everyone is basically saying this is
a beauty standard that
you guys created created well you know
what they
haven't they're being hoisted up by
their own petard
again they're being hoisted by their own
patard uh
so we so they're mad at this that she
is um the
victim of her own beauty standards
and and the problem is that everyone's
having is not that
it was sad what she wrote she was just
basically like do you have low
self-esteem this makes me feel like [ __ ]
is it a problem that i want this guy is
it so
she turns into the cop like well i guess
i can't i get i guess i can't you know
and
at the end what it is is not that she
can't
have a shitty day and she is the ugly
sister and everyone calls her all these
mean things
it's the fact that one you aren't honest
you she edits her pictures you can't
believe
the atrocities well that body looks very
different
just the body in that photo yeah is this
her
same she said this is me guys
just to prove all of it is something's
i feel i think her she's got a chest one
she's covering it up
she's losing a lot of blood and fluids
apparently the point is
why are you why are you why do you need
to prove
also no one would have noticed what do
you mean she just let it go
well there's also way uglier photos of
course and of course
just say any picture of kylie any
picture of you is just an old picture
kylie
yeah it's the perfect alibi that's not a
new picture of
me chloe that's old kylie go talk to her
buy her lip gloss while we're at it i
just think it's funny that they
are so like i'm human yeah but don't
want to admit any surgeries
don't want to admit to any augmenting of
their reality don't want to admit i mean
the
the photo she tried to pass off a photo
as
as hers and she said it was unfilled un
unfiltered unedited
you can it went from me to
i don't know name a linebacker like
the real the real photo was is not what
you're trying to portray so you're mad
when the jig is up yes
and now we all have to feel bad that's
what i don't like just be honest be like
i got my butt done since we're talking
racist phrases
come on jig is up that's a you know the
racist origins
nope literally just walk yourself
through it
i was on the phone call the other day
and uh
and i uh there was a couple black people
on the call
it was whatever and i was like no skin
off my back and then i thought about it
i was like
i think that's maybe the last time i'm
gonna say that
i'm thinking about where that's probably
from
thank you i just want to make sure i
gotta think look it up look it up
uh the phrase appears to have other
roots skin off my nose
there's a phrase related to effort put
your back into it that can apply
possibility of damage
but has nothing to do with slavery and
since we have just uh
entered lent i don't know we just
entered let neil
uh yeah i don't i it
it i heard it weird this is the photo
that she posted just so you know this is
the photo that she posted oh i remember
that
and then like this is the reality
yeah yeah now you're mad you're mad from
that you can't be mad
you can't be you when you destroyed this
yourself basically
she just hoisted her own petard she
[ __ ] snake ate the tail
hair the dog neal is on uh friendly fire
uh no skin off my back the original form
of this original form of this was no
skin off my nose
dating back to the early 20th century
but other body parts have been used as
well
all right okay all right i'm back we're
back at it we're back guys can't wait
till the next zoom
i'm gonna try to drop it a couple times
get on my back
and then not racist i'm gonna throw not
racist look it up
try to try to cancel me um this i don't
know what is bruce's beach
so speaking of beaches and the inkwell
bruce's beach was the name of manhattan
beach
uh it's called bruce's beach oh this is
the black beach this is black
most of the beaches in hilly were black
uh and now that's me hmm that's a hard
pill to swallow that's me
swallowing a hard pill yes hold it so
maybe the blm house
she's really that's how i that's how i
would spin it
no i'm going back it was originally
racial
equality and inclusion so basically
they chased these people off their land
and took
white people chased black people off of
a lot of the beach
property in l.a because no one wanted to
be at the beach because it was farthest
from
it's like lobster
yeah and like no one wanted it and then
they needed it at some point the white
people were like but
let's overcharge for this it's really
good actually let's make this a premium
yeah manhattan beach owned by
black people and um because
uh they weren't a lot of other beaches
so they made it inkwell essentially
i heard an interesting segregation story
it's like not good segregation but it's
it's one of those like
long tail things so they get the dp on
chase malik saeed
uh we were talking about we were talking
about
i'm having a guy shadow me um there's
it's a program
that's just getting started called
double the line
where young uh
i think it's either people of color or
black people
um can shadow me producer ken
can the dp no it's a
separate thing because i'm i'm always
like we need more black i've been saying
we need more black crew for
five years right and before that i was
fine
i just didn't direct commercials um and
so
i'm talking to malik about it he's a dp
and i was
he got a lot of this shit's just
nepotism right
a lot of the jobs especially in the
physical part of
production is just nepotism my cousin
right of course my nephew needs a job
whatever
i was talking to malik about how he got
started and
uh he said he the
union in dc used to be segregated
because there was people who worked
black there was the black union who did
the black theaters the white union did
white theaters
then they became one union and uh
which i'm sure both parties loved and
they became one union
and then but malik's dad was in the
black union
so then it just became easier to get it
for him
but there's so there's no growth
do you know what i mean yeah it's like
the or it's like no well we had
there were a thousand white people and a
hundred black people back then
and now it's just the same ratio just
now
it's just the same nepotism yeah just
nepotism but occasionally
i just didn't know about the segregated
union thing it was one of those things
where it's like
if not for that if there was just one
union then he wouldn't have been able to
get in
they wouldn't have any black but you
work with
crew yeah that are unionized
do you think they'll be happy about more
black people
no that's what i'm saying like but but
even today i don't think people realize
that
no well it's all guys that if they
weren't union guys they'd be cops
if they weren't lifting lights and
sandbags
they're all they all they're all like
there's an inside joke where they all
are from a certain area code they're all
from simi valley
crew guys they're all from midwest even
like but i'm saying
in l.a yeah and they all have boats that
they take out on lake elsinore
and they have big pickup trucks like
i've been doing uh location scouts to be
like those guys are in the 408
whatever the um or whatever whatever
it's not the
it's the type of union it's the union
number whatever
but just it's like okay
i'm i'm a guy who's trying to have more
black crew
how the [ __ ] do i break that how do i
break that
that that to me i can see that turning
a little ugly well by the way i think
chris mentioned
rock mentioned his dad was a union
driver
and they used to i think he'd be the
first black guy
in to integrate unions
other other like because he could take
it
and his son is the meanest man
you know what i mean like and that's how
you make the grizzled old
uh detective um but like that's
so how do i i'm like so i have a kid a
guy who's coming to work
with me for the the cool thing is they
get paid they get paid like pas
oh great um it's great yeah it's
it's great and i chase is gonna give
money to to the program that's
the best part um but
that i just never thought about the
segregated union parts but like
no oh this is such a deep problem the
weirdest [ __ ] i've ever been told on set
was from
crew dudes white dudes yeah
yeah like uh
one guy was just trying to show me weird
internet
this is this particular thing happened
when obama was president and it was um
he was trying to tough time for white
people yeah this guy was
a vic he was being so oppressed he
showed me how obama's trying to
eradicate christianity from uh
america and his cousin got denied
a grant i like i was sitting in the
makeup chair like
i was stuck so i just i have and as much
i've always had like a good time on set
but i always
get the feeling that it's a particular
type of
girl in that union republican yeah
trumpies
physical lifting
neil's doing the funniest act out of
these guys minor little actors
lifting it's just a little lift um
yeah so i don't know what do you think's
gonna happen with bruce's beach
no so something already did so so chased
off the black people
and turned into manhattan beach and kept
it very white for a long time
and now um they're gonna pay the family
they're the descendants it's one family
or it's a few
believe it's one family bruce bruce
bruce
oh it's that's her last name will and
charles bruce and it's gonna be like 875
million dollars
for the land that they stole
you'd think it would they may return it
to black people so
yeah it's fine it's either they might
return it or
pay them the the uh value of the land
75 million dollars which will get them
two houses in l.a
in manhattan pretty cool yeah uh uh
that's great that's uh that's massive
massive incredibly deep old problems and
they're going to be
very complicated to solve i just think
it's funny nobody realizes
that even watching the
exterminating all the roots like it
sounds like taking land with something
happened so long ago you know yeah
like no one's gonna come here like this
is this is my house now neil
well i had the thought that
the i'm someone i feel like a few people
talked around this dave kind of talked
around this about
the the reclamation of
meaning when they arrest drug dealers
they get
the the drugs the guns the house the
cars because it's it's a thing
it's based on crime it's all it's all
the spoils of crime and it's like
the punch line's kind of like uh a
defendant being like
well uh you guys better hide all your
[ __ ] because the native americans
are on their way over here right now and
they're not
like [ __ ] playing around yeah like
you're [ __ ]
right natives are coming to get every
[ __ ]
everything i do wonder why more natives
and black people with like
family that they can trace back to have
been like terrorized by this country
like why don't you sue the government
i know that sounds not like something
super easy but i feel like
anti-trust laws and monopolies yeah you
were saying racketeering and all this
[ __ ] that's like
well it wasn't none of this is fair
right
none of it's fair and by the way you
watch it and
i'm actually not whatever i want to get
into it
but i gave when i was like giving a
bunch of money
at the end of the year i gave a bunch to
native americans
because like i don't because you see
you you see it and it's like i gave it
to black navy
meaning you
you see it and it's so
atrocious it's so deeply
completely wrong like nothing about it's
right
yeah and the compensation they've gotten
is not even close it's
it's you can't it's like you can't put a
price on it you really
what white people did in america you
can't put a price it's priceless
it's like those mastercard communities
yes for everything else
yeah uh so have you been to a
reservation they're not nice
no they're they're like uh state parks
yeah the ones i mean i've been in
a long time but the images i have one
it's like
you know not good no so that's why when
people
[Music]
when people say oh well they got land
yeah it's like you want to live on a
reservation
they got uh they got a rest stop
it's what they're like rest stops that's
the same
architecture do you want to yeah do you
want to live here it feels
smaller yeah and there's not a lot of
resources
they got like barracks they have like
army barracks
yeah so at this country
it's we'll get into the birds in a
second um
uh the mcwhorter list not worth playing
um
the monkey played the video game i
didn't see it play it
it's very creepy oh my god
is that a real monkey yeah
they played a video game with his brain
i don't know the technology that's at
work oh
they unplugged the controller and it
still moves but you s
wow that's even crazier
wow somebody was heckling
elon musk on twitter like
i'm sure he'll do like he said something
about jurassic park something like
i trust this guy even it's like this
guy's a
[ __ ] genius he's a douchebag
yeah but the tesla he invented tesla
paypal uh the space thing
it's like this guy's a [ __ ] douchebag
in an asperger's case but like
like or whatever he's something
something
um and uh but neuralink is he created
this technology
he air funded it he's like very behind
it um
so yeah like people like [ __ ] you i
did it drive a tesla and then tell me
he's
you won't care what what he tweets also
i don't need my
world geniuses to be to be cool or
interesting yeah
or go on rogan even i could never know
him and it's like
i'd rather not i mean in his case i'd
really rather not know
yeah how do you feel i've never you
don't like when people do that
you know i don't like it do the thing
you're good at get back in the lab
uh get out of here stop trying to be an
entertainer
stop being a football genius does dork
does dork at the wrong time
um i love this game well you can play it
with a
macaque if you love it so much
um so i'm am i creeped out by it
yes do i like experiments on animals
no do i
but he's alive that's my thing with the
animal my
my thing with animal i'm like don't kill
animals if you can help it
you know the problem is i was when you
go when you deep dive
into all a lot of
medical doing deeper and deeper
discoveries and like uh improvements in
medicine
i mean if we did not monkeys
trail trail monkeys just if we did not
experience
literally a barrel of monkeys
a giant barrel of monkeys uh mongols
what the [ __ ] it's a giant medical
history
yeah is a it's a barrel of monkeys
i think it's like if you ever have any
kidney
liver lung like almost everything almost
everything but there is
one where specifically orangutans the
most
beautiful gentle without killing and
experimenting on them with
terrible just suffering monkey suffering
leads to us living i don't know to
paraphrase rick ross
shout out to monkey
um he didn't even it wasn't plural he
said shout out to pear
he said why doesn't he why is he doing
because he's cool he's
i don't know he's crazy uh he's rich
that guy
rick ross but he's rich from like
take his advance invested in car like he
invested
like houses car like not [ __ ]
businesses didn't scott storch it away
he didn't scott's torch
um scott storch of course looks like a
slightly overweight lesbian he does
why scott um
it's fine um now
yeah so i uh
you know the reason i don't eat meat is
because of what calves and methane
do to the earth and i think it's gross
and and you don't like the flavor
it's just inhumane i just think it's not
any flavor
no flavor justifies that even
my sweet sugar even my sweet ice cream
my sweet sugar does not justify the way
they treat
factory just industrial meat is so gross
it's
it's the grow one of the grossest things
they can what about industrial
dairy i mr ice it's the same
i try not to eat uh i try to eat vegan
i don't try that hard but at least
they're alive
and but with presents but it's like i
don't feed
keith vegan because i tried it and he
[ __ ] hated it
and i think dogs need yeah so like i'm a
i'm a hypocrite i'm just trying to lower
it
i know it's tough anytime you look at
did you watch c spears
well apparently it's a lot of shoddy
stats right
i told you i didn't like a lot yeah what
he was he went on i couldn't even get
through but i'll get to that in a second
i'm sorry tiger so tiger woods
got the he was doing 80
uh in a 40 and
he didn't get a speeding ticket can i
why didn't he get
can i have a question why are we still
talking about this [ __ ] didn't
happen like a month yeah but it because
they didn't know what the cause was
the cause was what it was um
and the cause was he was doing 80.
so but he didn't get a ticket
here's my and people are mad he didn't
get a ticket here's what i'm saying okay
if you crash
if your tibia breaks like a [ __ ]
twig can you imagine putting a ticket on
his car
yeah and like where is that yeah like
yeah what good is the ticket gonna do i
do find it weird we're still talking
about it though i know there's
new info but most successful athlete of
our time
okay that's all
prostitutes sex workers prostitutes i
can talk about i got it i got a dm
a text saying call them sex workers
because we were lapsing in the
prostitute
um so
so yeah but my thing is if you crash
there's your ticket
you know what i mean yeah in some ways
it's why
kevin hart can beat spokesman for 80
things it's because
he wasn't he paid his fine
with the oscars yeah so it's like well
yeah
and tiger snapped his [ __ ] leg and
can't walk so
that's pretty good i'm sure he'll
remember sure keep that in mind next
time he wants to speed
if that if we're trying to you know it
depends on what we're going for with
with tickets but it seems like it's so
they don't do it again
and i bet he's not gonna um if i know
tiger um now doc watches
oh you don't want to tyler i don't get
what shaq was that corporate oh the
shack in the ring yeah
i don't really see that sorry um are
they all related
no i just forgot oh cause i don't know
what shaq
i was just jack got a kid kid was
getting yeah scene okay go ahead
and uh the thing that no one knows is
that it's not they don't put it on
instagram but chat gets to have sex with
a lady once a year
for the next 10 years which i think is
pretty
pretty wild now the question is
not like i wouldn't even let shaq buy
that [ __ ]
it's does it feel like i bet if i was
the guy
the guy may come to regret it why
shaq bought me this right well
you know people don't always fight fair
and that's a pretty nice
that's a good one yeah like who shaq am
i engaged right to shaq
that type thing we're getting married
june 13th
and then me and shaq have an august date
it would be
it's forever going to be it's our
shackaversary
uh now it's nice to check to something
nice every day
um but uh but yeah the the
i just would you if he was like
what if you were buying a tesla and he
was like neil
i got this well if it's for me
i don't know if it's for if it's a
present for somebody else
it's a bit like the re-gifting quandary
like did you do it
or did shaq do it you know like he had
every intention to do it yeah
i it's not like there's there's worse
versions of it where like
he should just sell the ring and buy his
own
no it's still shaq's money you're right
there's no way to get
yeah like there's no there's no
there's nothing he can do um would that
bother you
if who you're the kid shaq came
it made national news so you can't you
kind of have to just go with it
i you have to go with it yeah but i
don't i
it's one of them things where it's just
one of them things
neal's face it's just one of them things
it's nice
yeah it's just i don't
it's not blm and malibu but it's
just it's a little it's just ah
the optics are not great yeah even
though it's in it it's good deeds and
it he's gonna require
he's in your marriage just like the two
of you are this is a marriage with three
people in it
um and one of them seven two um
yeah it's it you know who is gonna need
a lot of strength the woman to not bring
it up
i pray for strength for her you should
be favored pray for her
pray for her strength um and then
corporate
the corporate the corporates
the corporate vote they don't they don't
they're against corp
uh senate uh uh elected officials now
are against
corporations yes even though
it it's settled law into the supreme
court
citizens united says uh money is speech
uh but against speech isn't speech
and corporations are people yeah corbins
are people
and money is speech but yet somehow not
this time
it's another one of them those uh one of
them
wild double standards that republicans
have sometimes where it's
like not even it's like against me
jello those jello those gelatin ass
walls
that republicans have uh the gelatin
dividers
that they live with uh what flavor jello
though
bill cosby um the uh
yes it's just just one of them things
it's
uh this is one of the things like i
don't even this is like why are we
talking about this
because it's not even it's
it's just who they are yeah like where
you can't
hold them to they have it's the thing
it's
it's the stain thing that we did a
couple months ago where they you cannot
stain them
oh yeah they were stained they were the
yeah
the whatever the [ __ ] it was called
rainex
yeah uh they're they're covered in
polyurethane and
somebody the guy who made it in the
factory votes for them although the
polyurethane's killing
them let's not get into that it's
these are these people are they don't
have standards no
um and of course what are they gonna say
the cool thing is
will smith and anton antoine fuqua we're
shooting a movie there and they're
leaving atlanta
they're leaving georgia yeah atlanta
this is going to hurt
georgia well then you get into like
okay so they don't do the all-star game
it's a lot of black businesses
that get the problem is that will and
antoine like
you know did they bring in the crew from
it probably would have been a black or
crew
although antoine i'm sure you use the
black tp and
um so contemporary southern black folks
the dp can um the dp can
he the hires all whatever so
whatever it's not there is a there's a
there's unintended consequences [ __ ]
everything
um
we've talked about it twice already in
the podcast
i tried the q and on documentary let me
just get it out of the way i just didn't
i like i just didn't like the guy
i just didn't like his voice i didn't
like his approach
and like you said it was a bunch of it's
a
when a documentary's on a wild goose
chase
it's kind of got to be live and i'm
sure parts of it were but i'm sure parts
of it were structured
afterward like in mike mike uh the
roger and made michael moore's first
documentary
i think he met him and just said he
didn't
yeah like there's which i don't like
that
i don't i like i'm not glad he did it i
just didn't like it
i can't explain it no i think and it's
funny because i was talking to people
who were
talking about it who were finishing it
and
everybody said it gets way better
um surprisingly they said they felt bad
for the wheelchair guy
eventually sorry i don't know his name
um
the whole thing just seemed like a time
investment
i don't think i'm gonna get a a like a
utility payoff
it's a fake thing it's
so why would i care where it's from i
can't you know what i mean like
if it's a if it's a pyramid scheme i can
go for that right or
even uh vix vim the one
uh eventually i got tired of because
it's
once faheem pointed out that everyone in
there
volunteered for it i was like oh yeah
he's absolutely right
so yeah with this i'm like i
they just tricked i know how i'm i was
more interested in how it worked on
people
than who is it right i don't
apparently so i asked them oops spoiler
alert
i'll give you a second to turn it down
apparently the documentary is pointing
towards steve bannon
because they do a timeline of
steve's movements and how close he is to
the trump administration and when and it
lines up very similarly yeah
but even then uh okay i don't know i
just
it's not enough right it's still the i'm
far more interested in like his tactics
right or like
how i don't know or psychologically
are we this brittle like how and i get
they do
like i didn't know exactly the origins
of
q and on what they but it was enough i
don't know i saw
there was an article that i posted on
twitter that i i think we talked about
it's that apophenia thing that once you
see us
uh uh we talked about on here once you
see
a symbol if like this then it just
becomes like people making the okay sign
and then like you know what that means
when they find a picture of john and
chrissy
right doing the horns like the tech what
was the
university of texas horns among other
[ __ ] and the
um the [ __ ] rock and roll so then
they people go
it says six six six six sick and
it's not anything yeah um so
lesson learned uh now exterminate all
the birds we've
we've referenced it uh and
it's did you watch all four parts no
i've watched
two it's pretty it's dense
it's incredibly it's like adam curtis
but uh with heart
it's it's emotional adam curtis it's
like gutting yeah
it's not it's not uh
a mental exercise at all it's it's it's
completely an exercise in getting
eviscerated you just like eviscerate me
emotionally right
and it's also uh
as a so he has a white person
it's so damning and then you get into
like well what i
my people didn't get here until nineteen
days and they were irish and they
iris had their own [ __ ] slave and
then you go like maybe that's why blacks
and irish get along like whatever
there's all that [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
but it's just so awful it's so awful
like
the amount of indian necessary native
american tribes there were
and then the thing where they're shaking
them off they show a map
of all the native american tribes in in
america
from 1800s to 18 feels like around a
thousand well there's that treaty one
that treaty one is a whole other thing
no the truth
but between 18 hundreds and 18
856 and they just do the the ticker it
just goes through every year
and everything is getting shaken yeah
they're just
falling off the country and like opening
up for the settlers who came and settled
it
because they were so unsettled the
natives were so unsettled it's
just so [ __ ] uh
it's it it's it's like this
painful love letter you know
to the reality of white supremacy
the reality of i would not
love letter diary diary i just mean
i don't know whatever a heartbreak
letter is you know not necessarily a
love letter but
someone just like bleeding just like a
bleeding
heart letter yeah like this is
where everything you is this is where
everything comes from yeah
i don't care if you're cuenon or you are
blm or you're
liberal i've posted about it and a guy
was like
[ __ ] they so they said that
uh dropping the atomic bomb was racist
and i wrote back like that's the name
buddy that's
your only takeaway that's your only
counter argument right
it's like well that was [ __ ] it's
like what about the
100 other things in the documentary that
are that are not justifiable
at all also other than your
savages and were great yeah
also we start wars with brown people i
don't know what he's talking
like well it's just a guy who doesn't
want to it's like if you admit it
then what well yeah and you're right
what you're saying is so you
all that info yeah and you and mind you
that
that comes up in the first episode in
the first quarter
it probably didn't get through a lot the
the bombing yeah doesn't it oh i don't
know i thought it
i i don't even i just remember i don't
think it's in the third episode because
i
haven't been there and whatever i
haven't watched it but i saw the
i saw some of that and haven't got there
i don't know who knows but
at least like you it's so hard to deny
because it just goes back to the origins
of
everything we know and a tote and
told the told the wrong story
it's like well if it's great tell the
story yeah
if it's great like if you actually
believe in
what you did if it's justifiable just
tell the story
we slaughter them because they're
animals
like that why be like and we the
pilgrims
right there was a mix-up and i don't
even you know what's funny is
i don't even know what i learned it was
amazing i don't even know what i learned
like you know what i mean
i can say what i learned in two episodes
i learned the no no no no
in in brutes i learned everything sorry
what are you talking about
oh i'm saying like i don't even remember
how they sold it like
there were natives then they they were
well they were in they were called
indians back then
engines well indians just when i went to
school
and they i
was thanksgiving we learned about
thanksgiving
i we learned about hunter-gatherers we
just learned about it in a very um
compartmentalized way and yeah like and
then i don't know they left
and then you know pocahontas
it reminds me of a funny story
uh like lorne michaels is very good at
like
spinning things and he was saying
uh he was talking about somebody that
worked there and got fired
at time live and he goes he didn't stick
around long
right but that's kind of like they were
natives and they didn't stick around
like no well what do you mean you get
you fired that guy
what did you do to the natives i don't
know they just
didn't show up they kept not showing up
um the so yeah it is like uh
what can i think peop
why people think of like the holocaust
and they go that's wrong
right trains [ __ ]
chambers like that's wrong and that
those people deserve protection and
recompense right
you look at native americans you look at
slavery
and it's so much worse
and staggering and but it's not
photographed very well and it's not
filmed so
but even the but the skills of the
[ __ ]
the genocides that are uh documented
are they still getting attraction you
know like in africa and
rwanda was fairly well documented was it
fairly well cared about on well no
that's a whole other
that's what i'm saying it's like i think
it there is something about
i think it really does when you see
white people being mistreated
yeah i think it just you know white to
white
it's that thing where they don't think
black people have pain like they won't
give
right there was wasn't there a this
study
okay so let's ign let's assume
that it's a
dead it's a wonderful closing argument
the mind assume it's a wonderful closing
argument
what should what could white people do
to make up for that i'm literally
watching and i'm like
i think i had to have to retire from
being white
like i just have to retire and stop like
just not
i don't know like i literally like what
could i
do that would in any way
compensate for this okay well me
or and all white people let's think
about it like what
can so let's say you and an ex let's see
there was a
domestic violence incident what do you
do she hit me
go ahead uh
you you just you got a little your
spirit padre yeah
relationship ends right what do you
you're a nice normal person you want to
make it up to her you want to make
that wrong right like do you go 30 grand
i mean like imagine you're not okay
imagine you're not rich
therapy you know
for us you what do you do to make sure
you don't
dv someone again do you go to therapy do
you do
what everything you could do does it
make what you did
palatable i mean doesn't it make it uh
is there is there
what i'm saying is the scale of it is
so major i know something that it's the
it's i feel like we've talked about this
before it's it's the garage that white
people do not want to clean out
no and it's
rarely do you get clearer glimpses of it
than that documentary that documentary
lays it out so specifically year but
month by month but it's also laid out in
a way
a lot of it's not linear necessarily and
by the way ladies you could do worse as
the
the recurring white man than josh
hartnett i was like
ugh don't make him sexy why do i can't
help it girl i'm like
oh couldn't you make him yeah they
didn't look like that that's the only
criticism
make him look like they really look
because josh harnett was
josh hartnett's the only i've ever seen
women
chase him down this literally i remember
on broadway in new york
in like when the movie that it was in
came out the
he was in he was in the uh one of the
pearl harbor was he in pearl harbor or
some armageddon he's been hot
since i was a child um
and women were chasing him down like
puerto rican and black women not like
[ __ ] teeny boppers they didn't know
what he had done in the 1800s
i also wanted like if i see him i'm
gonna be like that was a
i don't want to say it was brave but it
was like that's like uh
ow it was a cool it was cool that he did
it
yeah because it makes it makes him look
it's
like it did it's like where people were
like in uh
the black messiah and judas and the
black messiah uh
lakeith stanfield had to go to therapy
and stuff was like that looked like some
therapy [ __ ]
i mean the [ __ ] that he did like
chopping it like yeah
yeah so um so whatever not like he's in
any way here but it all just is [ __ ]
traumatic it was yeah um that
i feel like when and uh
i guess we'll get to but when we people
don't like you know
black uh trauma porn and stuff like that
this i can this is so informative
on things that how do we get this
information unless you're going down a
serious
k hole you know what i mean like you've
got to be
this is such a wormhole to get like did
you know did i
and sometimes it's so atrocious that you
because you haven't heard of it before
you wonder if it's wrong you're like
no no when it told me can't be right so
when you see it all laid out there is
something so impactful
when it's just like laid out beautifully
that what do you
how what there's
it's very hard to
stomach the fact that you
never had a chance against white
supremacy that's that my takeaway was
like
you never had march i'm not saying not
to march but
right there you stand
no chance against it also makes today's
white people look
somewhat reasonable like you know what i
mean like allowing a march they wouldn't
allow that [ __ ] in 1900
like that [ __ ] was [ __ ] it was
barbaric
it was how they treated everybody evil
and ruthless so
[ __ ] evil that oh
that's where it like i
i understand the suffering part we
really get the suffering
even if you don't get it you're like
someone tells you something like okay
sure
it's the way they lay out the
like the oppressors and the the people
carrying out the suffering
we kind of don't talk about that we talk
about how [ __ ] up
of the the guys to the administrators
yeah we don't
really because we just assumed yeah that
was awful but when you really get into
how
someone had to [ __ ] take it upon them
that's what i was thinking dave one time
said
like racism
[ __ ] up everybody and i kind of didn't
know what he meant
and then watching that i was like that
guy that guy's so
[ __ ] up yeah it's he's so it's you
it's
it's you want to talk about like ptsd
like super juicy
those people you see what going on
iraq does to people and they it's not
like that much
action right i mean it ended up being a
lot of action
and whatever i shouldn't say that like
but i'm thinking about like the original
gulf war in like the 90s
um but it's just that shit's
bad for people like it is bad on a
person
yeah i watch an old documentary that
showed people coming back from world war
one
they're the black and white people black
guy crying
you can't and i remember my teacher said
who i will write up anybody who laughs
like this is not funny
yeah i'm not showing you this so we can
like laugh at that which
when you look at it why would you show a
group of high schoolers this it's
what you're asking for it's honey trap
tony trevor in an inappropriate life but
i that's when you realize the human
brain is not meant for this kind of
do we are our biology
is there's a huge disparity between our
biology and
the evils we're capable of yeah what we
can do
it's that repeat murderer thing it's
like one percent
right a murderous repeat because it's
like oh i didn't like that
you saw guts coming down like i know
i don't want to do that again not for me
thank you enough
nope not gonna it's gonna be a while for
me um
so that's when i watched it i was like i
don't know
i i can have interns i can have a black
dp i can you know what i mean like i can
do it all the [ __ ]
and it's never going to be enough man i
don't mean like
and that's why i'm not gonna do anything
i just mean
it's uh when you see what you're up
against
when you see what the history that
you're up against
having a black guy shadow you
yeah seems yeah it seems like
condescending
it's just like all of it but that's like
but and then there's also a thing of
like
i you know what a human life is like and
like
i'm conditioned to want to make a living
to succeed to achieve to do
to accrue my own property and all that
[ __ ]
in a world where i'm doing it on a pile
of
you want to i mean a pile of [ __ ]
uh death and atrocity the
my uh literally all i kept saying is
this is curse
this is indian burial ground
cursed country by the way i'll some of
it reminded me of ayahuasca and i won't
get and
did you have that i was getting a little
weird out i was get
i mean when i tell you my first
third my first third of ayahuasca
was someone saying do not forget you
were a slave
yeah and was saying they want you to
forget don't forget and every time i
looked at my hands
they were an old lady slave hand
yeah i got some flashbacks i was like
it came through so strong yeah just the
looks on the natives faces was like not
a good way we're living because the way
they they've never been photographed a
lot of the natives
yeah so they don't even know how to like
they don't know to do three-quarter they
don't know any of the poses
and they look like they're live a stark
life
before white people got there you know
what i mean like it's a hard [ __ ] you
live outside
um so yeah
so that's neither here nor there
everything all roads lead to iowa
of course at some point but but yeah it
was it's uh
also it's one of those things like give
yourself a week to watch it
also when they what hurt me so badly was
how
um these i don't know
colonizers came and didn't have any land
or labor
and took it from the natives by force
and they said why
why do you have to take something by
force that we would give you willingly
give you
through love mm-hmm i was like
yeah everyone's evil like yeah they
would have given you
it why did you have to rape and kill
them and threaten to
kill and rape all their children and
women
like they would have just given you it
out of the sheer love for you as a human
being yeah
this is that that is
that's where you go really [ __ ]
uh not like natives are
i i can't speak to what natives are like
in their soul
right uh that was just a quote no of
course
and and i'll take them at their word i
guess it's like
what the [ __ ] happened to white people
in general
that are make them like that like you
know what i mean like
i literally thought of farrah khan and
malcolm x at their most vitriolic being
like
white blue eyed devils and you're kind
of like ah
when you go back far enough yeah like
yeah
make it arguing against it yeah this
behavior what do you
how else would you explain this behavior
it's not human
it feels kind of like no i'm getting a
little hokey pokey here
but it does feel like we just it i don't
know in some ways it feels like this is
just
kind of one big experiment like let's
make that
half of them dark let's make half of
them
like equal it's that classroom
experiment where it's like there's the
blue kids yeah
i don't know when i mean i get
like doesn't religion have a lot to play
with if you go back enough
yeah well that has to do with like
punishment
that's that had a lot to do to me with
like
the how brutal they were because it's
like
you know biblical [ __ ] yeah it's like
it's yes it's like spare the rod spoil a
child and beast
it's just all that [ __ ] but it has to
come from somewhere because
i mean there are
like in this country there's not a
history of
terrorizing doesn't it goes kind of one
way
yeah you know it's not like oh it
naturally occurs in all of us and you
know everyone
thieves and steal like terrorizing
someone else because of the way they
look goes one way and i'm not
saying that black people aren't capable
of being racist or ignorant
or an asian people latin people of
course but
i i mean i guess they don't really cover
asia that well but it seems like
asia was wiling out as well their own in
their own sort of they just didn't
travel
it was just far yeah it's too far
because we'd love to we'd love to
terrorize you just too far it's like
uh yeah like uh what's his name
genghis khan and all that [ __ ] like
africa is far too though what the hell
uh i don't know
i don't know it's not far from here it's
not that far from europe
and so so i don't or maybe
i don't know when i'm so i'm i don't
know enough about history
but i and i don't even want to say like
it's not it's not just white people
um because asian people clearly were
wilding out as well
uh and i'm sure there was tribal [ __ ] in
africa and in south america
prop but let's say it was less
especially with african south america
that which brings me to like what
happened to white people that made them
like this
that like made made us
or them whatever you want to call it
like that it's just it's like some
do we have it bad spirit [ __ ] like do
you think it's in our
i like no one wants to admit this but
is there something in us biologically
that
not like white versus but is there just
somebody if you're in power you're just
prone to well yeah there's like the
there's studies that
wealth makes people less empathetic
more entitled there was a just a stop
sign
study of what cars stopped
when it's four-way stop who
who waved people through wow really yeah
and it wasn't
that wasn't wasn't the foreign cars
it was chevy's fords of course toyota i
mean toyota like it was
it was 25 000 cars drivers were more
likely to weigh people in
than tesla's and
and mercedes it's [ __ ] hilarious
that's so
fun yeah um so
there is that but i don't think most
white people were rich most people were
farmers
no it's such a small amount but even
when you look at the
the it is statistically people in them
in the world
most people were farmers until like 18
something right but the
when you look at the the documentary
goes into
how britain treated um and like
conquered and treated
treated ireland mm-hmm
and that's when it's like then it just
becomes a class that it just keeps
becoming like
they people will take a difference and
use it as right
that's justification for any sort of
behavior so are we all capable
of that level of evil or but why
historically it seems like it
historically seems like
most of the time white right but if they
do it to
white if they do it to other kinds of
white i must
i don't know enough about asia to say
i'm but i think they did it also
yeah because when i've been to china
they've been like
[Music]
oh they're all like and then i was
talking to somebody about how
like their dad hates their dad's chinese
and hates chap
like just weird like
minor no of course but but there's no
even the difference between a white
person a blackbird
like when they they have scenes where
they get off the boat and the
natives are touching their hair and it's
like it's not that [ __ ] different
from yours
but it's like this like different it's
different enough
i mean me and my brother traveled in
europe when he has a full afro
yeah the amount of people who wanted to
touch my brother's hair
yeah in the 1600s no but it's not but
even like people are people do what's
funny is chris had the joke when it's
true that his daughter was afraid of
dreadlocks
his black daughter just when she was
three or four is you
scared scared of dreadlocks that's not
i get it that's not like and therefore
white people are
just as because of chris's daughter uh
wait then it's even
um but i'm saying i i'm i even if it's
just
white even if it is just white people
which i don't think it is but even if it
is like
what the [ __ ] happened and now what
that's what that's what
my takeaway is like now what
i not even like
[ __ ] you now what just like okay
it's weird because i always used to
think that um
in this country the way you know white
supremacy played out
and just like the way racism played out
in this country is
it really got kicked up a notch when the
slave street stopped and they needed
slaves to they weren't important well
then slaves yeah and they also needed
them
to then they made that tricky
move over to humanity right there we go
and it's
it was less about like oh you're paying
off a dead you get to keep your culture
and it just was more about you're
inferior because
we need you for free labor and economic
prosperity so
i wondered what if instead they chose
you know what for this weird country and
for it to
for this experiment to work let's
actually
not do it based on race because even
what they said you know how like the
what they set out to do with america was
a novel idea at the time like
freedom like we don't have nothing
nobody rules us
democracy throw in throw in racism in
there because that also was
like that also i just wonder i used to
wonder if what if they chose
to try to that be one of the goals they
also tried to yeah like
and then i see this documentary it's
like didn't stand a chance that wasn't
even
gonna did that had the momentum of
800 years like to like and now we'll
stop yeah it's like
that's but that's the as a
well you saw the [ __ ] up thing with
slaves all going america in brazil
so many went to brazil like way more
than i even thought
but the caribbean got more slaves than
any other country
because british slave owners were so
ruthless that they didn't even
get to the age to procreate like
they were killing 20 year old like
healthy men that they could not
procreate so
i think the caribbean has like
five or ten times more slaves that went
to it
yeah through england than anybody else
which is why now
it's funny that america has
this terrible stigma which it deserves
but i'm like
no one's talking about how terrible the
conditions were in the caribbean because
of like the sugar cane and
all that stuff so right but it's still
white people so it's like
close enough i mean it's just called
america
yeah i think that's but mine it's
because they have their own countries
now
supposedly like you know even jamaicans
are in jamaica
right right but i don't think jamaicans
were whip were
chopping people's hands off and [ __ ] no
they were just dying
right that's the the message i uh the
message that i get
from people of color it seems like it's
like
just stop it just stop it
i we don't is it reven just stop it
yeah i'm [ __ ] begging you stop it
because this shit's
unbearable and to dave's point it [ __ ]
white people up
not in a like not in a way that's
anywhere near as bad as what it is
but it's like it's not good for anybody
to treat some you know
to have a packing order based on
pigmentation
um the the other
argument that someone could make it's
like yeah but look at all the progress
that was made
inventions uh
progress by who say uh in the world
and uh [ __ ] medicine invention
and you look at this and you go nowhere
near worth it
yeah there's another one it's like no
invention is worthless
and there's not one i'd rather sleep in
a [ __ ] hut
than than
i think it's so brutal
you know how we as human beings it's
very hard for us to
um understand how rich jeff bezos is
it's just
it's just we can't just we cannot
understand it we have to break it down
and yeah he spent a million dollars
every second of you
i think the brutality of our history as
human beings
is so brutal it's the same thing it's
really hard to understand
it's unfounded how much rape and
body mutilation and uh unfair treatment
it's just too much it's like that unfair
yeah
let's just breeze by this chapter you
know and that's why his i mean
i guess that's why roots was so i wasn't
around for roots coming out but
were you sorry no i mean i
no no hard no
bianca i said no i think it came out in
79.
it might have come out i remember it
airing around 79.80
but i think it originally aired in 73.
i'm so confused why
it was that it was like the number one
watch thing why i don't i didn't know
why people liked seeing that [ __ ]
couldn't have all been black people
watching no it was not vibrant it was
it was like uh
i think the nation was more christian
then
and the christian thing seemed to be
like
a confession and by the way
it's completely sanitized relative to i
mean they had to do a narrative it's
like a guy and then hey
hey like right fiddler enough hey it's
not
it was [ __ ] brutal day and night
start every single day yeah brutal
brutal brutal brutal it's like the scene
in 12 years of slave where it's
that that y'all the one in the yard
where he's hanging and
you just hear like like the rope and the
every day for your whole life your whole
kid's life
their whole kid's life their whole kid's
life they're
seven generations or something yeah
probably more
i'm not i don't i still don't know what
it how long a generation is
it's 400. no it's not i think it's 25
no i know obviously oh okay um
so i mean
yeah i just don't know it's so good
though like
it's amazing it's poetic it's incredible
weaves in between um his life
yeah uh it it jumps back and forth it
shows a lot of
imagery in like old hollywood and yeah
old movies i've seen so many of those
old movies too
i saw that one i also i hated the time
machine as a cat i was like this movie
sucks
i didn't watch it no it's a terrible
look like the everything's not
the savages are so savage you know it's
very
like poor this poor guy going through
but what i'm always wondering is like
what's the it's and it's the same thing
for black people
who are these black savages i keep
hearing about
do you know what i mean so
they defy every statistic when when
is this super negro
was it in the 1500 like was it in africa
it's the it he actually makes the point
i made
later which is it's it's a karma thing
yeah it's you think if you're stealing
from somebody you expect them to just
come and pop you at any point
like so if you're you're so bl it's the
the two karmas they were six foot three
and six foot
four karma and a sweatshirt like that's
it's just this white people are kind
so then it's they do a psychological
thing where black people are
super predators because of their own
guilt and shame
and like who where
where is it i haven't seen it no i know
that's just so great
where is it at there's like
the cannibal hannibal like the cocker
hannibal like
i guess he was a dope warrior i don't
know but he wasn't
seemingly uh cutting hands off cutting
heads like
the [ __ ] are you talking about yeah it's
a it's a myth
and it's a myth that they
they created to to justify their own
[ __ ]
like i have to right you have to do that
okay well let's just cut up
children's hands often yeah for rubber
but
you don't know what i'm dealing with
back there like
they are this is a necessary
way to mitigate the savagery yeah and
it's
and they're all in church that scene was
fun that was like wild
i mean what at some point we have to
what i don't get is there's no
situation on earth that just keeps being
unfair and fair and fair like
things do balance itself out you know
what i mean maybe not
immediately in this case but i'm
wondering
what mark of justice is like dr king uh
real quick how long and the bend
how subtle is the bend and how long is
this arc
because this is wild how long this is
i think if everybody saw that
documentary in school i think there'd be
i i think it would lead to unrest
if everybody just realized how [ __ ]
it's so
sad do you know what i mean it's so
brutal i don't think your first instinct
is to punch somebody no i don't think
to punch somebody but i when i watch it
i'm like there's
no way to fight this machine
of racism it's so like ingrained in the
foundation before this country even was
a country you know yeah so how do you
fight
that marching like it just made
everything seem like
oh no yeah this is weird
we brought like sticks and stones like
here's a resume all right one
yeah it was depressing
um like i when i watched so he's the
same guy that did i am not your negro on
a bunch of films
i'm not your negro i liked it i didn't i
just didn't love it there's a james
baldwin american experience
that i liked more okay but i liked it as
a documentary i think there's
i've seen better things on james baldwin
but i liked
yeah if like you've never if you if
that's how you get fine yeah and i just
i like the way he
i like the way he tells the story yeah
the the
peck yeah but
this is like i'm not your knee who's
like the appetizer
i'm not it makes i'm not your [ __ ]
look like cool running
stupid um anyway exterminate all the
roots just want it's just give yourself
give yourself time after time
just to lay down because it's so
it's so not a date night it's so rough
it's like it's beyond crying
you know what i mean like it's like so
[ __ ] eviscerating you're like i'm
crying wouldn't even get help this
it's like it's so deep that you just
like okay
anyhow let's we do a podcast buddy and
we do emails
what's up neil and bianca talking about
buffets in the last episode
the question was will they come back the
answer is
unequivocally yes half of this country
would have flooded into a buffet
no questions asked at the height of the
pandemic
there's nothing to make me think that
once regulations are dropped
they won't be right back in those
buffets and
the thing is that the crazy thing about
this pandemic
as it pertains to a lot of americans is
people don't treat it as though it's a
pandemic they treat it as though the man
has made some rules that they don't like
and so as soon as those rules go away
they'll be back in buffets
peace first of all he sounds like jonah
hill
he does sound like second of all uh
the thing that he's not accounting for
is lawsuits
if you if i can prove i got covered from
your buffet you're in trouble
if they i thought they were gonna i
thought there's a thing that like you
can't sue for covet
no you can see i mean a woman got 30
days for coughing on somebody
and then awesome that's amazing she does
your one import
30 days that's jail [ __ ] also at pier
one
i know of all places keep that filled
out please
um but uh no the
no the suing over covet thing is that's
for the vaccine
you can't sue for the back if you've if
you get side effects from the vaccine
like it's like
yeah okay what are you gonna do well
where are you gonna go
tell that to hank go to another go to
another uh go to another
um planet it's like um
so but so that's my argument for against
my face but i think
i think they'll be back i think it'll
just be like a two three year window
or just a one actual window
and someone does it for you it's not a
buffet honey
ew it's supposed to be sweetie it's a
man's buffet
like uh like like a carving station
okay you you that you don't touch any of
this you don't touch
one person that's [ __ ] expensive
though meaning
it's like you need 15 more workers
so i hope you love a 90 dollar buffet
dude
look i got the money yeah
i'm good i host a podcast i'm coming
goodbye
you've got mail i'm curious as to what
you and bing's thoughts are on the
backlash to quote-unquote black pain
stories
uh that i see on twitter all the time
notably to lena weith and them
but also i've seen it around a friend of
the show trayvon freeze two distant
strangers
it's really weird to see all these
threads of people uh dogging the shows
and
you know saying oh i know that not a
single real black person was involved in
this
stuff like that um especially when
you know from the champs episode that he
was on and just following his social
media presence in general
trayvon seems like a very smart very
well-intentioned
guy who i would imagine is probably
bummed out that
uh people are having this sort of
reaction to his show
or his his project i don't know neil
have you talked to him about it
you know mainly just want to know uh
what neil are
and what banks da da about it all thanks
uh you know what's funny is i have not
talked about it because i didn't when
you guys
texted me about it today and by the way
this is exactly the kind of [ __ ]
me him and roy would talk about right
like exactly so the fact
so it's kind of hypocritical that it
hasn't been brought to the to the chat
what would you what would your general
take be well my general take is
they're they don't
like they don't like the tone
because by the way
your average hip-hop album has a 45 body
count
yeah on it but it's just it's just
fun and we're numb to it yeah you're
we're
it's fun and we're numb to it uh
exterminator brutes has a it's an
atrocity
it's atrocity after atrocity after
atrocity and curiosity
is that plain porn i don't know but i
would i think i mentioned it i think
exterminate all the brutes it's
different than
trauma porn because it's
i mean who had this information you know
it was a really like
sit down and okay i'm gonna accept
some trauma you know what i mean it's
kind of on your own terms it's kind of
like
that was rough whereas i think a lot of
people are getting annoyed
at fictional work from black people
at this now in this kind of time it's
like okay cool you have
the flurry of the platform what do you
choose to bring to the table
and now i do think people are getting a
bit fatigued
on the like uh
opens the door cop
like all that [ __ ] is just it's a lot
and it
makes you feel bad you know what's the
worst black trauma point i've ever seen
is the news
okay that's my point my point is like
you're good
the [ __ ] you it's what do you want him
to write about
but do you get i think i get i used to i
had this argument with the
dave not even it's not even an argument
he was like
his take on the wire before he watched
it was
black people suffering something and not
that entertaining to me
he didn't realize he didn't watch it
though he hadn't watched it he then
watched then he watched it it's like
okay oh
okay um but i get the impulse
but guess what they would say if they
weren't telling these stories why are
you whitewashing
uh the black people's experience in the
country
you why are you sanitizing it doesn't
have to be white why are you sanitizing
i think at this point though
because there is this one um god i don't
remember her name her marissa
she's i think on blackish she's like a
young girl she's now like a
national grownish not the main
daughter but she has a development deal
and she
she put out a statement saying there you
go um
marseille martin she put out a statement
saying she's like
no black paint in any of her the thing
she's putting out
okay i mean it's gonna be fables that's
what that the
it's where do people want
that's a part of you know
i think part of it is the the it's the
that seems to be the
overwhelming dish served to black people
right is there trauma yes is violence
now it's the overwhelming dish
in america i would argue for black
people is that
so white people can do a cancer story
and it is it white trauma do you know
what i mean or like uh well no
is that again this is like some graphic
murder but if you think about it
uh i i think saying it's a fable
is wrong because most people's lives
most black people's life isn't riddled
with near-death experiences with the
police
yes i know it depends on where you live
and it depends on what's going on
i would also argue white liberals kind
of think it is based on
it's like of course white liberals are
reading black trauma porn
exactly but if you think about remember
when donald trump said black people took
photos of their back walking down the
street like i'm good and
they were all shot later on uh but
i think it's just a misconce it's it's
like how there was like
that weird genre in the 80s and 90s of
slave movies like
you know what i mean there's just well
like slave movies i mean
it's not like a weird genre but yeah we
like a lot of
i felt like the most slave movies came
out in the last five years
oh no like rosewood all right that was
90. that was 20 something
no no that in rosewood was not in the
90s late very late night i don't know
who yeah
i'm just saying there's 84 yeah
um there's like
85. my point is that
the ones that win oscars the ones that
they greenlight the ones that they give
any um attention and money to
really end up being those kind of
traumatic things
and now and my encounter would just be
holocaust movies
are like the white version of that like
can we tell some jewish stories there
are tons of jewish stories that aren't i
totally agree i think it's not a i think
it's a matter of
i i think
i think it's well-meaning i think it's
well-meaning on the part of white people
i really do i think it's white people
are like
uh we don't because as wipers you don't
get accused of
underdoing it do you know what i mean
you don't want to accused of
be accused of uh you know
hey you're not going to get as many woke
points if it's just about like
the inkwell right um
of course read the script
um i actually want to go a step further
and say that in half baked
i was like it should i like the guy in
the inkwell as like a
thing and like we kind of agreed like
yeah that was a good
like a normal black human being yes yeah
like
um so
i don't fault white people for
thinking that this is a relevant
thing to it's like a responsible thing
to do
you know what i mean like it would it's
like if if someone comes in
here's the opposite someone comes in
with a slave when you're like
nah enough with the pain if you're a
white bird it's just you're in a tough
spot
no for sure for sure or a black person
because then you're like a self-hating
my person if you don't want to do a
slave movie
but i think everybody's saying because i
like it's not like get out came out and
was met with
backlash no like we're good but at this
point
uh it feels well but get out was fun
though
do you know what i mean it was like
within 12 years of sleep obviously
it was bleak as [ __ ] like what was the
other us
uh like all these movies that were
are just winning awards and doing well
across the board
i think i think everyone's just getting
a little fatigued
on the pain part yeah i i also think
it's a thing to tweet that i think
people it's like
because i feel it i think of course i
remember i ge
i get the impulse it's it's like um
i remember telling a woman said
something about black representation in
movies
i was like black men need better
representation in life
you know what i mean like what they need
more law they need doctors
like yeah and then like that will follow
it's they're following the sort of like
just [ __ ]
this [ __ ] a black architect to [ __ ]
out of here
right or you know what i mean like a
thing that it's like it you
the the risk is either fake it
or make it aspirational or make it
uh i i
get where everybody's coming from i
think the problem is like for example
the
um who's the name
ava did it it was about the kids in time
but not
time oh yeah when they see us well they
see it yeah
i tr i couldn't watch it it was i tried
and it was just so i mean i'm sitting
there trying to relax
heart beating like yeah blood boiling it
is just yeah but ava's made the 13th
selma
that like and i watched all of them but
i'm just saying after a while now we're
getting the a law of diminishing utility
now it's just like hey she also did the
one
with oprah the st the little girl one
right but it is
now it's starting to become the law of
diminishing utility yeah it's like okay
guys
like i think the problem is we dissect
white lives i mean to that's
millimeter you know and i remember my
friend was trying
to pitch this show that got picked up
and dropped and then picked up and
and they said it's basically they're
like well it's basically a male version
of insecure
it's like so no too many too much
to too many voices we already have
insecure so you can't have it was about
it was like well done and it was just
about the like a
black male like a young male going
through mental health issues but it was
funny
it was interesting and he was going to
try to do meditation and
yoga and um
uh therapy and how it just didn't work
being like from south la and yeah
working at this
and it was like no we already touched on
that so i think there is
a i think there is something there i
don't think it just
that's what i mean like i don't think i
don't think it's a fake problem because
charlemagne's told me the same thing
like
it's the thing like when i let me tell
you i
there was a podcast about that very
famous hanging
photo of the guy getting hung and
it's podcast about that day in indiana
and it's the it it's so
banal the day and it's but it's
heartbreaking right and riveting and all
this stuff drama
and i had to decide like should i send
this to black dudes i know
yeah i d and it was like i almost wanted
to write a cover letter
like look like look i
i i tried to listen to this slave
um podcast that had recordings of
slavery slaves that you
yeah and it just was i know and it's
like
and you every time you're like did you
listen to the slave thing yeah i did
it's just very i know it's like it's
a hardship and
and it's you got to talk about it and
i'm sick of talking about it
and do we need different freedoms like
should you just send that to white
people
well do white people care you know no
because i
uh like there were white people i'm sure
i sent it to but like
you know darker ones okay um there were
white people i'm sure i sent it to but
like i don't it that it just felt like a
responsible thing to do
no idea like whether and then they were
all like yeah
yeah of course but but it feels a bit of
like a cheap shot
like how often even deal even writing
with the
black it's like is race part of this
is this ra is this just a normal thing
or is this a
race thing is it is race going to rear
its head or is this just like some human
and it's it it
i think the the bigger problem is life
in america
and history and then how do you
represent it because
i don't because i think like i said the
opposite is the opposite's probably a
bigger problem
the the sanitizing sanitizer problem but
maybe someone just wants to see i don't
know
just like the inkwell i mean the ankle
it's funny that we keep bringing it up
because it's like no not the inkwell
like the i don't know diving bell in the
butterfly but
mega black i don't [ __ ] just right
just some [ __ ] nice film
yeah yeah
agreed that isn't about race
well that's we i mean yeah to bring the
tv show up again it's like
we would only do one race thing in
episode kind of
really the whole thing felt like i i
know race it wasn't
i'm like you it was i know what what if
there were it just
it's so more than one an episode
it just got a little like what else
that's why we just do like boobs
like just like let's talk about titties
[Laughter]
because it just gets like it's like the
compression level just gets a little
much yeah
and but as a white person
you want to be sympathetic it's coming
from a decent place if i'm pitching a
thing and it's like
hey take it easy yeah with the race
pitches and it's like i don't [ __ ]
know
because if i don't then you go like well
you know this is a big issue for me
right so with trayvon's movie with
trayvon's thing
is there a reason why he chose to make
it
about you know is it just because what's
going on in the world of course it's
every day the black guy gets shot an
honorary black guy get shot every day he
wrote a
really good thing about it with john for
the daily show it's not like a
he's a 6'4 black guy like
he he's a you know it's not like he's
white people are like oh
and cops it's like oh he's got a nice
car like
there's a bunch it's a thing it's
preoccupying i would think
um but the this idea that it's somehow
it's the assumption of bad intentions
that i that's where i get
like that's where i get like that's a
[ __ ] cheap shot on your part
to say like he had the idea right
i think it's if you look i read this
book that
um categorize all the different types of
roles in which women won academy awards
and golden globes and it's always
degenerates of society
yeah it's always you're either sex
worker
or an alcoholic or drug addict or you're
being abused
those are the ones we want to see women
in those are the ones
not we want to see but those ones that
get applauded and awarded
in hollywood not
women being great or like doing great
job or positive
imagery at all so i think there's
something
to that where we kind of we want our
women degenerates of society
and that's what we do
hey y'all look what i brought that bass
it's stupid
and i think we want our black people
traumatized we want our blind people
in a little bit of field well that's
there was that argument with
uh denzel that he won for
for playing training day
but not glory philadelphia
filled up yeah but then i'd go he was so
[ __ ] good in training day he was so
[ __ ] good like
cubic in junior was so good in jeremiah
it was just like [ __ ]
bang they come on screen and like bang
yeah but then the english patient wins
and it's like
boring right but that's that's like i
can't
yeah i don't i don't think that's white
people's taste
do you know what i mean like that's why
people say it's remember
uh joke about it
no one outside of new york or l.a like
birdman no no for sure
like no white people like the [ __ ]
english people but is it
black people's taste no of course whose
taste it's
the academy's taste okay but obviously
that's an extension of something right
it's not true i think a better thing
would be
box office like that's a better
indicator of what we'll accept
and it was wonder woman that's the
number one movie female director female
lead and guys we're gonna end the
podcast on that
before bianca can counter
white people i don't know why people
meet me in venice we'll discuss what to
do about
eliminating the brutes eliminate those
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
you